皆さん
エボラという病気を知っていますか
正確にはエボラ出血熱と言い方なのですが
ニュースをやってますか
どこで起きていると思います
はい
アフリカのコンゴという国のエボラが
の近く
エボラがここです
このエボラガーの近くに見つかったウイルス感染すると
頭が痛くなるん
熱が出て
しばらくすると
アナとかを知りからたくさんの血が出て
死んでしまう
しかも
映った人たちが周りにどんどん広がっていく
多くの人だいたいこの病気にかかった半分くらいの人たちが
死んでしまう
恐ろしい病気なもぅ
とても夢なり映画にもなりました
ニュースで聞いた人がいるかもしれませんが
今この病気が
アフリカの西側で広がっています
もちろん石鹸を使って手をしっかり洗うとか皆さんにとって当たり前のことをするだけ
でしっかりと予防できる病気でありますが一つの国だけではなく
アフリカのあっちの国やこっちの国でも
英語等の病気が広がっています
江原の病気にかかってしまった人を元気にしたり
これ以上病気が広がらないようにたくさんのお医者さんたちや看護師さんたちがあっち
の国はこっちの国へ出かけて行って一生懸命この病気を抑え込もうと必死にがんばって
います
アフリカのことだから書けない
世界中の人たちが行ったり来たりする今
アフリカと日本は遠い国ではなく飛行機で簡単に飛んで来れる距離です
もしかするとこの日本にもへご覧の病気がやってくるかもしれません
つまり
この病気はアフリカだけの問題ではなく
世界のみんなで解決していかないといけない問題なのです
でも
この病気と戦うことができるのがいい
お医者さんや看護師さん達だけでしょう
例えばお医者さんたちを応援するためにお金を集める方法があります
病気を治すことに詳しい人たちがアフリカに行って十分働けるよう
飛行機代や薬代などを見ない出してあげるのです
この応援の仕方はすごく大事ですが
それはお金を持っている大人がやるべきことです
皆さんには何ができるでしょう
お金を呼びかけるために募金バッハを持って駅前に立ちますか
折り鶴を折ってアフリカに送ることですか
たぶんこれはやめといたほうがいいです
なんにもできないから
大人が何とかしてくれるのを見ていればいいですか
僕には3人の子供がいます
一番上のお姉ちゃんは花という名前の7歳の女の子です
今年花と僕は一緒にエボラの病気と闘っているお医者さんたちを
別の形で応援しました
どうやって応援したと思いますか
7歳の花と僕は
お医者さんたちが必要とする地図をたくさんの人たちと一緒に作ります
もちろん日本にながらです
自分の家でインターネットがあれば誰でも参加できます
チーズというとどんな地図を創造するでしょ
秘密基地に隠したたからもチヌ
世界地図
おばあちゃんすに一人で行くあないぞ
江原という病気が広がっているのは例えば
リベリア
ギニー
シエラれようにポイッた
アフリカの国々です
みなさんこれらの国々がどこにあるかわかりますか
よほど中朝が好きでないとわからないでしょう
どんなところが想像できますか
もしかしてライオンやゾウが歩いている風景を思い浮かんでいませんか
これはお医者さんたちも同じです
普段行ったことのない初めての国に行くのです
どんな場所でどこに何人くらい住んでいるのか
都会など
田舎なの
どんな病院を作ったらいいのか
どのくらい薬を持っていったらいいのか
傷はそんなわからないことを教えてくれる大切な情報です
けれども残念なことに右側にあるような
みなさんが普段目にする地図帳やインターネットの地図にはそういうとても大事な情報
が十分に描かれていないかもしれません
傷は誰かに必要とされて初めて作り始めるものですがそれはとても時間がかかるお仕事
です
世界にはまだまだ地図がちゃんと作られていないところがたくさんありますが
エボラの病気が広がっているのはそんな場所が多い
だからお医者さんたちがアフリカの国に飛行機を至っても
しづを探しても
大事な情報の地図がないということに気付きます
こういうことは2010年にも起きません
場所は
アフリカではなくカリブ海にある配置という国
10深部であるポルトープランスという町でとても大きな地震が起きました
30万人を超える方々が
なくなりぽても悲しい出来事でしたが地震が起きた後みんなが気づきました
ポルトープランスん傷がない
そしてすぐにインターネットを使ってみんなが地図を作り始めましたオープンすると
マップという名前の
みんなで作る地図の仕組みです
12jan 2010年ポルトプラフ
すが起きました
地震が起きたと
いろんな人たちが膝を作ります
白く光った瞬間が誰かがどこかを編集したとき
膝を描いた時です
それが道路を描いた瞬間かもしれません
誰かが建物を描いたかもしれません
港の壊れた様子を地図に描いた人もいました
だいたい1000人以上の人のおっに顔の知らないメンバーが
インターネットを使って地震によって壊された町の最新の地図を作ったのです
今を駆使光っているのが避難所のもんじゃ
地震が起こる前のオープンするとマップはこんなスカスカな家です
地震が起きたとこうなりますん
わずか数実知らない人同士がインターネットを使ってしかも仕事ではなくボランティア
でこれだけの地図ができたことは驚きでした
実際に配置の人々を助けに行く世界各国のお医者さん
消防士さんたちが僕らの地図を片手にポルト+の街を歩き救援活動を行うときました
このように遠くの場所からうんたぁネットを使って膣作りで
応援することを
crysis マッピングと言います
クライシスとは大変なことが起こっているということマッピングは
地図を作ると言う
僕も覆面男人もの日本人がこの時一緒に家創りに参加しましたが何より
日本人で一番小さな参加者は当時中学生です
今はもっと活動しやすくなっていますそして仲間も増えています
今オープンするマップには世界中でおよそ200万人の傷を描く仲間
ボランティアが集まっています
2010年のころは今のない体重分の1ぐらん
パッチの配布-4-9
ん
ブーブー言い戦術は大スーパ今年10歳の感情ました
無洗米のなく
一人のイギリス人大学院生が始めたプロジェクツ
これは google マップが誕生する1年前でもあります
んん
話を
エボラの病気の話に戻しますん
7歳の娘ハナとエボラの病気が広がっている町のクラシスマッピングをしました
今でもしています
小さなノートパソコンとインターネットがあればこんな風に
たとえばここに家がありますよとかここに道路がありますよとか
一つ一つの作業は小さなことかもしれませんがたくさんの仲間と一緒にすることで詳細
な地図をみんなで作ることができお医者さんたちの力になります
ちょっとやってみようかな思いましたか
そんな時はお父さんお母さんにこう聞いてみてください
子供でもできるオープンするとマップやってみたいっ
まだエボラとの戦いは終わっていませんが今年の8月には建物がほとんどなかったこの
場所
11月にはこんな細かな地図が出来ました
今もどんどん新しい地図が作られています
こどもも大人も
男も女もハンディキャップもある人もない人も
それぞれの立場で自由に参加できる地図づくりがこれから世界を救うかもしれません
今日は
こんなメス所 t シャツを着てきます
一億総伊能か
いノートはアド時代に日本地図を作った伊能忠敬のこと
日本人1億人みんなが彼のようになったらいいな
そうな女生
伊能忠敬が日本全国を命がけで測量して回ったり
しづを作ったこと
今皆さんはインターネットと gps があれば簡単にできてしまいます
娘の花もおとうさんから教えて貰ったら後は1人でゲームをするかのように江原の病気
を地図を
書いていく
そんな誰でも自由に傷がつくれる時代
それを目指すのが1億総評か
もちろん
世界では70億そういうのか
ぜひ
あなたも
マッパになりませんか
ありがとうございました